[Music]
thank you everyone for attending
this will be the first in a series of
three webinars that focuses on
how to use reproducibility in a business
setting
and the real gist of what we're doing
here is over the past few years as you
may know
academics have been very concerned with
the problem of reproducibility in data
science research
uh here's just one of many headlines
that the public has
has read about reproducibility this one
comes from forbes but there's been
you know a quote unquote reproducibility
crisis and data science research
and there's been a lot of progress made
to address that crisis
and from a technological standpoint the
problem's been solved
in my opinion but there are many
cultural changes that still need to be
made
the cultural changes don't concern us so
much as the technological solution
the new technology that data scientists
are using to make their work
reproducible
has created unintentional benefits for
people who use data science in a
business setting
and that's what these webinars will look
at the first webinar which you're at
today is reproducibility and production
and i'm going to talk about the
technological solutions to the
reproducibility crisis
specifically one type of technology that
i'm going to call computational
documents
which are just documents with executable
code inside of them i'll show you how
you can use those create opportunities
both for yourself
and the people who consume your data
science intelligence whether that's
customers
clients bosses colleagues so on
in the second webinar on september 18th
thomas mock will talk about rstudio
connect and production
our studio connect is a production
platform that allows you to share the
types of documents that we'll be talking
about today
and it really completes the circle in
terms of providing
opportunities and advantages in an
everyday business situation
in the final webinar kelly o'brien will
talk about interactivity
which is probably the largest
opportunity created by the technology of
computational documents
she'll go over the best practices for
making interactive material
and tell you the things that you should
be considering as you develop
interactive material for others to
consume
that webinar will take place on october
2nd
so for today let's start by looking at
what
computational documents are this is what
i mean by computational document
let me accept the slides vermont go to
rstudio
this is a computational document it's
just a regular document a file you can
see text in here
but it has executable code
embedded throughout the file and a
computational document is just a
document that contains
executable code and when you can put
executable code
into a document then you can allow the
reader of the document to run the code
and the code can do things for them as
someone who knows how to write code
you could write whatever code you like
to do whatever you want the reader to be
able to do with your document
but
this document contains a data analysis a
very simple one as a matter of fact and
the code here just recreates the
analysis and this is typical of what
computational documents do they're a way
to solve the reproducibility crisis
by putting the actual reproducible data
analysis in your report so whoever you
pass the report on to has everything
they need to recreate the data analysis
for example i could run the code that's
in this document
press these buttons and reproduce the
document as i go
so here this analysis is making some
graphs we'll look at in detail later
and then the other thing that this
particular type of document allows you
to do
is you can knit this report both the
text that the author wrote in the
document
and the code that runs the document is
combined and so we see the text here
with the code results and it creates
a finished presentation to pass on to
someone who wants to know about our
results but maybe not about the code
so that's the gist of a computational
document it is
something that can contain embedded code
and because it can do that
it can automatically reproduce a data
analysis done with code
and you can see here how computational
documents are a definitive solution to
the reproducibility crisis and data
science
everything we need to reproduce our work
is here
but because we are reproducing it with
code
not only can we just simply reproduce
analysis we can reproduce the analysis
automatically that automation
is what creates opportunities for
businesses who want to use computational
documents
another one as we create opportunities
it's going to be a disruptive technology
that changes how you think about
delivering and performing data science
if you deliver or perform or conduct
data science
as part of your job to put that in
perspective let me draw a historical
analogy
go back to the slides uh
this is a picture of the printing press
the printing press famous example of
disruptive technology
uh when johann goonberg introduced the
printing press into europe in 1439
no one could really foresee the sort of
changes that it would
catalyze in society now the video here
is stressing the reproducible aspect of
the printing press but that's actually
a red herring you know monks can
reproduce books by hand before anyone
came along with printing press what the
printing press did to change society is
it made the reproduction of books
automatable
it took a little bit of initial setup
but after you did that you could
automatically automatically reproduce
books now compare that to a
computational document
it takes a little bit of initial setup
to write the document
to put the code you want inside the
document but after you do that setup
reproducing the analysis or reproducing
the tasks that the code does
is automatable you could pass that
document on to someone who doesn't know
how to use code
and they can automatically do what you
design that document to do
what sort of changes should you expect
this to trigger downstream
well again consider the printing press
when it became automatable to reproduce
books
many things changed for the first time
in history it was now profitable to
create a book to sell
and that gave rise to a huge new
industry the publishing industry which
is still with us today
for the first time in history authors
had considerable economic and political
power
and that triggered new laws copyright
laws which protected authors from
you know publishers and people trying to
steal their work and also censorship
laws which protected the public
supposedly
from the authors another thing that's
that's very prominent when people type
the printing presses for the first time
in history
the bible was no longer a black box
people could look at it without an
intermediary
in the form of a priest or the church
and they could develop new
interpretations on
what they were working with and that led
to new conflicts
and then just more generally after it
became automatic automatable to
reproduce
this sort of work it became beneficial
perhaps for the first time for the
common person to learn how to read
i think some of these changes are things
that we'll see on a much smaller scale
as computational documents become
more and more used in our fields
there's two main benefits computational
documents that we're going to focus on
today
and the first benefit is for authors
when you use computational documents to
report your results and to deliver the
insights you develop with your data
science
you can start reporting those results
much more efficiently
you could reuse the same initial work
the same setup that you put into making
one document to create many many
documents
the second change that computational
documents facilitate
is for users the people who consume your
reports
that you generate with computational
documents can interact with the content
in new ways
ways that might be very valuable to them
ways that they might be very excited to
have and even willing to pay for
so we're going to look at how you could
create computational documents that you
could use
in either of these ways to make your
life better
for the remainder of the webinar we'll
look at our markdown which is a
technology that makes it easy to create
computational documents
i'll give you some tips about the
features of our markdown that i think
have the largest payoff for using
computational documents
in this sort of business or production
setting and then finally we'll think
about
how to include interactivity or not
include interactivity in the documents
that you make
now throughout this webinar in the two
webinars i follow in the series
we're going to talk about the word
production and i want to be clear up
front that
production means different things to
different people and we're aware of that
so please don't be distracted by the
word production if it shows up in these
webinars
but that we we just mean that these
materials that we're showing you are
ready to use
however you want to use them and with
whoever you want to use them with
so we've looked at the promise of
computational documents
now let's look at a way for you to make
computational documents
with r there are many different ways to
make computational documents
we're going to focus on just one known
as our markdown
and again i'll leave the slides and go
to a demo here
all right the example documents i showed
you earlier right here is in our
markdown document
and our markdown documents are just
plain text files
but they contain three different types
of content so if we look at this file
here you'll see up here
sflextension.rmd don't let that fool you
everything in this file is just a
character and a plain character at that
so this is a plain text file that makes
it easy to
edit to save if you wanted to
use version control on this file say
i have this file saved so if i delete
this and save it again i could come over
here to my rstudio tracker
go to webinar on my way follow this o2
rmd
and i could diff it and since it's just
plain text it's very easy to read what's
changed here this is like a git diff
uh it's also easy to save on on github
and that sort of thing i'm not going to
save this change because
it's not a productive one but this file
and the other ones i'm showing you today
are will be available at the short link
i'll share it again at the end of the
webinar that contains the materials for
today
so we're looking at our markdown file
and we see that
it does have text here it also has code
as we saw before
and it has a header here which is just
some metadata about this file
the three types of content are
demarcated by combinations of characters
that's what allows us to remain a plain
text file so if you have
if you want to have code in your file
you can surround it by three back ticks
and any program that's aware of this
file format will be able to recognize
that there's
executable code between those backticks
if you want to make a header you can
sign up surrounded by three dashes
and if you just want to write plain text
well you could just write plain text
although i have added some things here
we'll talk about in a bit
since this is a plain text file you can
open it in any text editor
but i would recommend opening it in the
rstu editor because our studio is
designed in some ways to be a text
editor for our markdown files
the rstu id will automatically locate
your code chunks in here surrounded by
the backticks
it'll allow you to play them in that
fashion i showed earlier
you can use this as you write your
document to make the document
effectively a notebook a notebook
interface
you could write your code test it out
see if it does what
you want make the results go away if you
don't like looking at them but if you do
like looking at them
they appear right here next to your code
and then finally
our studio id provides the nip button at
the top of your document
which allows you to use this plain text
document to generate a new document that
contains the same content
at the moment this document's set up to
generate an html file
the html file has everything that's in
the original document including the code
results
in this case i asked for it for armor
studio not to include the code itself
because i thought that would be
distracting
and you can see this is an html file i
could share it on a website whatnot
rstudio opens up a preview so i could
see the results and read them
and then if i look down here i will see
that the actual file being previewed
exists in my directory and that's how i
could
take it and share it and do something
with it like i said this document set up
to return html output
but i could use the drop down menu here
and i could create the same content as a
pdf file
none of this really affects the plain
text file it creates a new separate file
this file is a pdf file so if i
submitted to a journal perhaps or
going to print this out maybe i would
use the pdf versions of the html version
and then also i can make a microsoft
word version
these are just some defaults that come
in our studio for making these files
but the idea behind our markdown is you
can use your plain text file
to generate report in a limitless number
of formats
each report will contain the same
content but it will be adapted to a new
format
in this website ourmarkdown.rsu.com
formats
is a enumerative list of the options you
have available
for changing your plain text on markdown
files into new types of files
each of these are a function or an r
package
that can handle an our markdown file and
turn into something new
you'll see you can make books websites
blogs packages
no shortage of things with our market
files i'll click through the flex
dashboard one this is a way to make
interact
well to make bi dashboards with our
markdown files
and you know if we look at some of the
examples
maybe click through on one of them
here's the dashboard
it's made with our markdown if we look
at the source code here you can see
you know here's the familiar our
markdown header separated by
dashes here's some code chunks separated
by backticks and
you know there's some formatting here it
tells what should be a column and what
not
so to recap the strengths of our
markdown
they're just plain text files which
makes them very portable very usable
but you can embed code in them which
makes them a true computational document
when you author in our markdown file you
use our studio id to have a notebook
interface if you like that experience
for testing out your code
and then finally the whole idea behind
our markdown is that even though you're
working
in a plain text file you could generate
a report that's not plain at all
and in fact the report can be in a
variety of different formats
so far in my example i just use the knit
button in our markdown
but it is worth noting that
you could also generate these things
programmatically there is a function in
our markdown package
called render and if you send it the
you know file path to your file save
type completion will help me here
it'll render the file for you
programmatically so you don't even need
the rs2 id you just need an r terminal
to render these files
if you do it programmatically our studio
id isn't going to open a preview or
anything for you but the file will be
regenerated
and it will be saved next alongside your
other file
so now that you know the prop the value
proposition of our markdown
let's look at the features of our
markdown that will be the most
successful
for making computational documents to
share with consumers of a
of a business nature i'm not going to
show you
every single thing you need to learn to
create our markdown files
because i've already documented all this
in a self-paced tutorial at this website
our markdown.rt.com
begins at slashlesson1.html
this tutorial takes about you know 45
minutes to maybe 90 minutes if you take
your time to finish
and when you finish it you will be an
expert at our markdown
it's very simple technology you just
have to learn the rules and they're easy
to reapply
it take you about the length of this
webinar to learn this
but i'm not going to use the length of
the webinar to teach it instead of
focus on the more high value features
here i'm also not going to go very down
into the weeds with our markdown
because all the details are documented
at this website bookdown.org slash
uh our markdown which is the book down
version of an actual book available for
purchase
but the the book is available in its
entirety for free online at this website
and it documents
any questions that you might have about
our markdown
instead what i'm going to focus on are
the features that i think
will pay off the most for you watching
today so first of all
first feature how do you create an our
markdown file if you want to create a
markdown file go to the rco id
go to file new file our markdown
and when the wizard pops up just click
ok this will open a file
that has a template inside it you can
read the template if you want it tells
you a little about our markdown format
but typically
you would just delete everything and
start writing your file
or you can just open plain text file and
start rainfall same thing
so let's start writing a file um
i'm going to try to recreate the report
that i showed you earlier
and to make it easier i'm just going to
copy and paste some of the text over
here
all right so i'm starting my report the
graph below displays the adverse events
reported for
a drug this report is going to look at
pregnosome
which i'm pretty sure i did not spell
right there well maybe i did
and the most common side effect of
periscope i happen to know is that the
drug is
not always effective
which as side effects go is you know not
the worst by far
okay so this is a report this is a very
simple report i could write a report
that goes on for pages but right now
this will be enough for us
when you write text in our markdown you
can mark up the text for example
if i put asterisks around it then our
studio will know
that i don't want those asterisks to be
in the font report but i want the words
between those asterisks
let's save this somewhere
i want those words to be italicized and
font report and so here i have
adverse root events are in italics
there's about two dozen signals you
could use to mark up
the text in your final report i'm not
going to cover it today but you could
learn it in the tutorial
that's what adverse events and the
asterisk around it does
instead i want to focus you on a more
interesting way
to to change your text in reports
you could type out your text by hand
which i've done or you could use
our code to generate text for you so
first
let's put some r code in here i'm going
to just copy over the setup chunk from
the report i'm trying to create
put at the top of the document what this
chunk does is it loads some packages
in the helper script it makes some
functions there it takes a drug
it takes an age range it queries the
fda's open
fda database to find out what adverse
events or side effects are associated
with that drug in this case pregnant
zone
for people of this age range and then it
makes a data set out of those
those things right here the data set is
called events
if i want to find out what the most
common side effect is
in the events data set that's where drug
ineffective comes from
i could look it up myself and type it
out or i could ask
are to find it for me so i do i have a
script or one script it's in the webinar
files contains all the code i'm using
today
it's as a script this might be how you
typically write our code there's no
reason not to write your r code inside
in our markdown document
i just have this over here so i can copy
and paste throughout the webinar
i've written this code earlier events
dollar sign terms so it looks at the
term column of the events day set
and it finds out which type of event has
the maximum count
so this returns which side effect is the
most common for this drug
if i want the results of this to finish
my code
i could surround it by backticks
and then after the first back to put the
letter r in the space
now when i knit this report the reports
go run that code and insert the results
right into my line of code here
so it says drug ineffective because that
was
you know what you get if you run this
code if i run this code in the console
perhaps we'll see that
it adds it right into my report as long
as my code returns something
that's like a number or a piece a
character string that can be inserted
into text
i can use that code to finish the report
for me
the reader won't know which parts of the
report are hard written in
with real text and which parts are
moving parts that can change as the
results of the code that generates them
change
all right so that's the first thing
let's add some markdown to make all
events a
header here if i want to
to put a code chunk in here i could just
type out the backticks
it's all you know just character
conventions after all but i prefer to
use a keyboard shortcut which
in this case is option shift i option
control i
inserts it for me or you can go to the
insert button up here
and it will insert a code chunk for you
wherever you want one
an interesting thing revealed by the
insert button is
you don't have to insert only our code
chunks you can run
any type of code you like in an r
markdown document
for example i could run python code in
my document with the python code chunk
you do need to tell r what type of code
appears in a code chunk
so you type the name of the language
inside a set of curly braces after the
three backticks
now i'm not a python user so i'm going
to stick to our code today
but if you're interested in using other
types of code in our markdown document
specifically python code i recommend
that you check out sean mopp's recent
webinar
rstudio and python a love story
all right let's use this code to do
something
again i'll draw some code over here and
i will use this code to make a plot
here's some ggplot2 code that makes a
plot i'll put it in this code chunk
and if i knit the document i've now
added a plot to my report
but the code that makes the plot also
appears in the report
so this is my second tip if your
consumer is not an
r user i wouldn't show them the code in
your report
it makes an experience that that they
will
process psychologically very different
than if you just make a plain text
report like they're used to reading
if you want to hide the code in your
report you could do that by adding
a knitter chunk argument up here after
the r in your code chunk
and the argument i suggest you consider
using is echo equals false
this will cause the results of the code
to appear in your report but it will
hide the code itself from appearing so
now when i knit this document
i have my chart but i don't have the
code that creates the chart
to be honest normally if you're making a
graph people don't care what code you're
using to make the graph this one inspect
the graph
that's what echo equals false does for
you
all right so we're slowly building up a
report
it's probably a bit of a whirlwind but
hopefully you're in a sense that
it doesn't take too much to write these
reports they're actually fairly simple
all right echo equals false isn't the
only knitter option to consider
uh but it's if you want to write more
options you can just start typing and
then use ours to use tab completion for
a list of possible options
but learning about these options is a
bit tricky i confess because echo
and code chunks they're not our
functions so you can't open an r help
page to learn about them
so what i recommend is that if you want
to learn about chunk options in our
markdown go to this website
ua.name knitter and it contains
basically the help pages for every chunk
option
in our markdown this would be the place
to go to it's the first result when you
google
our markdown code chunks or knit or code
chunks
now that we have some code you could
consider this a complete document
if we look at what we have over here run
again
uh document
says okay uh the graph below displays
adverse events report for prednisone the
most common this is drug ineffective and
here's the other ones on the graph
this might be all your consumers
interested in and you could pass this
off to them
but maybe the consumer gets sick and
they go to the doctor and prescribes a
second drug
and they want to know what the adverse
events are for that drug you could
recreate this analysis
create a new report for them and send it
off to them but when you're working with
code
usually you don't want to repeat
yourself one because it's more work
two it invites the chance to make more
mistakes but three and most importantly
when you're working with code it's
normally not necessary to repeat
yourself
and now that we've written this code
it's not necessary for us to repeat
ourselves
we could reuse this report in multiple
places by adding report parameters
and to do that first we'll have to add a
header a header
is a section of the report that doesn't
appear in the finished document
but allows you to enter information like
metadata that customizes how the report
is generated
to make a header surrounded on each side
by three dashes
it should come at the start of your
document it is a header here you could
do things like set the default output
for the document
this would be the output that gets used
if you call the render function instead
of choosing one up here
one of the the things you can set here
is a parameters field you could learn
how to write yaml
and headers in the our markdown tutorial
so i'm not going over it but you can see
it's
key value pair separated by colons i'm
going to create a parameter
i'm going to name it drug and i'm going
to give it an initial value
of prednisone or whatever you want it to
be
and now that i've created a parameter in
my header here
the code in my document can access the
value of the parameters
as if they were a list and actually i
apologize for writing parameters
params is is the field now my code
can access the params list instead of
you know having a hard code prednisone
here
i could just access pram's largest drug
and this will return the value
prednisone because i set that value to
drug here
if i want more elements being that list
i could have you know
name whatever parameters i want and set
them to
whatever i want them to be i don't even
have to use them all
i do have to spell correctly so let me
fix this
now that i've created some parameters if
i go to knit
it's going to knit my reports go use the
default value of the parameters and i
won't see any changes now i'm talking
about prednisone
but if i come down to knit with
parameters i will have the option before
i need to report to change
either of these parameters so we've been
looking at prednisone but let's look at
a different drug like tylenol
now when i nip the report wherever pram
star sign drug appears in my code
it will return tylenol if i wrote my
report in the correct way
this will change the entire report to
speak about tylenol instead of
prednisone
and you can see here i miss some places
but the graph is talking about tylenol
and
the most common effect of tylenol is
nausea
it doesn't take much to parameterize the
whole report to use this new preamsarsin
drug
for example down here where i said
prednisone well
i could insert some inline r code and
that inline r code could just return the
results of
perhaps dollar sign drug this inline r
code is actually pretty
pretty useful because this is going to
turn the drug name and maybe i would use
it up here to create
a title and now when i knit this
document
i have prednisone here if i knit it with
parameters
stay with tylenol
i get my tylenol document i can now use
this document
in a similar context to describe any
drug in the database
i've automated that work by putting
parameters into my r markdown document
next let's look at another opportunity
created by the fact that there's
executable code in this document
there are two types of code in r that
return
interactive components one type is
called html widgets
html widgets are a collection of r
packages that contain functions and the
functions build a javascript powered
self-contained widget
normally to make a graph that has
interactive properties
and then there's the shiny package which
provides
ways to toggle in a live r session and
to interact with that r session that
runs in the background of your document
let's look at each of these separately
because when you combine them with our
markdown documents
you very quickly have a way to create
interactive reports for your consumers
start with html widgets the best place
to learn about them is the website
htmlwidgets.org so let's go there
let's jump right over to the gallery
each of these entries here is a
different type of html widget that does
a different thing
these widgets are sort of pre-programmed
to use out of the box
they all do their thing and if that
thing is what you want then
it's your lucky day you can just start
using the widget if you want to do
something that an html widget doesn't do
well
you won't be able to use html widgets
you'll have to use shiny and we'll look
at that in a minute
you can see that most of these html
widgets are designed to make
graphs for example we can make a map
that we could toggle here
make heat maps and read off values
but for our report since our graph is
just fine the way it is i'm going to use
the underrated
dt tables widget
what this widget does is allow you to
actually explore the raw data in a table
and to add it to my my plot all i have
to do is
you know maybe put some text to set up
so this will be our appendix
the raw data is available below
and then i'll borrow some code from over
here
i'll put it in a code chunk
again using echoes equals false do
backticks
get my document
and now as long as i pass this document
on in an html based format because this
is a javascript table
users can explore the actual data they
can sort by the different variables in
the data sets
or they could decide how much we want to
look at it once and so on
so it adds real value to this report and
all i did was call
a function that already exists in r to
insert
this interactive html widget into my
document at a certain place
now like i said html widgets are really
good for doing what they're designed to
do
but they're not very flexible for
creating new functionality
on the opposite of that spectrum is the
shiny package
shiny is designed to let you do whatever
you want to do in an interactive fashion
because shiny website here's a very
simple example shiny app down here
you see i have a drop down menu that i
could use to select different things
the graph output created with our
changes when i make different selections
i can select different dates overlay
smooth line
and do this and that's the graph the
idea is the user gets to control
some inputs the inputs are used behind
the scenes in our analysis
and the output of that analysis being a
graph a table text
or what have you is displayed to the
user and that changes as the user
changes various components here
that's a very simple shiny widget or
shiny app but you can see that you can
make some more
interesting and complicated shiny apps
here you normally design an html
page that sort of serves as a ui to the
app and then you set up the r
session and the code that runs in the
background
well you do that with our code and since
you can insert our code into our
markdown document you could do that in
our markdown document as well
i have a document that does the same
thing we've been looking at but it uses
shiny functions like render plot and
whatnot
to make the document we're just looking
at interactive
this document is now a shiny app
a little bit of trouble here there we go
all right so here's the shiny app it's
showing us tylenol's results i've also
brought it down by gender here here's
our table at the end
uh we could change the age ranges for
tylenol
sound like this uh see that
biggest side effect for tylenol is
complete suicide didn't expect that
for older people it's fatigue and if we
want to look at another
drug let's say advil
we could type in right here in the app
almost immediately changes this is
actually
and truly a shiny app made from an r
markdown document you can see the
document here
if we were to add the flex dashboard
formats to this app
we'd have in our markdown document but
this really looks like a shiny
a shiny app now uh so this is a
dashboard version of that app
and uh made through our markdown
all right so let's let's pause i mean
there's quite a bit there
i'd like to recap what we what we looked
at
when you're making computational
documents with our markdown the
opportunities you should pay attention
to
are actually generating the text of the
document with code
using inline code because if you do that
it will pay off when you parametrize the
document next
don't think of it in terms of r to give
it python sas
javascript whatever you like to use you
can put that into an r markdown document
so more exotic languages will take some
work on your part on the back end
the things used for data science like
python are ready to go
hide the code from your users if they're
not looking for a code experience
and then add parameters to reports to
make them flexible
your entire report becomes like a
function in r that takes some input and
returns some output
and all you have to do is change the
input to change the output
if you're generating the text with
inline code you're actually
able to change the results that are
reported to the user as the parameters
themselves change
consider adding html widgets for
self-contained interactive pieces
and then consider going to adding shiny
components if you need to do some sort
of custom interactions based on your
unique
r algorithms if you look at these things
that we went over
you'll notice here at the end these last
three options are sort of like
a hierarchy of ways to make your report
more and more interactive
and you could think of this hierarchy of
interactivity from static or markdown
documents on one end
to shiny apps on the other end which are
completely interactive
tools all of these are available for you
to use
and so now as someone sophisticated who
can make computational documents you
need to start thinking about
your strategy for supplying needs using
these different levels of interactivity
so let's look at that thinking about
interactivity
not only does each rung on this
hierarchy create a more interactive
document
it also requires more work on your part
interactivity is complicated to make
when it comes to making something like a
shiny app those of you who've
made shiny apps you know that there is a
lot going on there and that is a very
specialized undertaking to make a shiny
app
but you don't have to make a shiny app
every time you want interactivity
for example if you just want to generate
the same report but on a new drug or on
a new market segment or on a
new updated database you might be able
to do that with the simple or markdown
document that's been parameterized with
parameters
alternatively if you want your user to
be able to poke and prod the document
you might want to create a shiny app or
you might be fine within our markdown
documents that uses html widgets
or even in our markdown document with
shiny components
what i recommend is that you aim for the
level of interactivity that's as simple
as possible to do the task that you want
because that leaves less room for things
to go wrong and need to be debugged on
your part
less room for things that go wrong and
for the user to have a poor experience
and less time need to create those
documents here's some simple bright
lines that you could use to think about
this this hierarchy
first of all
if you ask yourself how many times do i
need to
change the data in my report during my
presentation
or during the viewer's presentation how
many times are they going to need to
change the data for themselves
if it's less than once then you don't
need anything that involves shiny
this is a very important question to ask
yourself because
we tend to see people learn shiny and
then use it for everything it's very
hard to walk back from shiny once you've
adopted a shiny workflow and that's okay
shiny is excellent
but it's very easy to overestimate what
you need to accomplish the results you
want
and if you're not updating your data
more than once per session
then you can just use a simple non-shiny
r markdown document
and you can create a new document before
each session and that document will
suffice for that session
the next thing to ask is do you need to
create a custom ui
for your your app if if what you want to
report to your user
would you find in a document format or a
dashboard format
you could do that with an our markdown
document and you don't need to invest in
creating a shiny or an html ui
to contain your interactive components
all right that is computational
documents in a nutshell
and hopefully from there you can see how
you can choose some of the benefits i
mentioned
i think the case for generating reports
efficiently with parametrizer marked on
reports source speaks for itself
and then adding interactive components
either through parameters
or html widgets or shiny components uh
would be the way to empower your users
to do different things
but we've really only covered half of
the user story
computational documents create the
opportunity to give your users a
document that can run code and interact
for them but whether or not that
opportunity will exist
at the user's fingertips will depend on
how you share that document with your
user
the platform you use to share the
document
will need to be able to run and execute
the code in your computational document
if you want the user to be able to
execute that code by interacting with
the document
and that's what the next webinar will
focus on september 18th we'll look at
rstudio connect
which is a production platform for
sharing data science
products among the things that you could
share on our studio connect are our
markdown documents
and shiny apps in short you can share
your art your computational documents
computational documents create a lot of
new opportunities
for letting people interact with the
things that you make and our studio
connect is built to take advantage of
each of those opportunities
to give you a taste of what's happening
last
i've taken one of the documents that
i've made in this
this webinar material and i've put it on
a demonstration rco connect server so
i'm going to a website now
the website is an rstudio connect server
when i get to the website i can see all
the content that i've posted on on our
studio connect
and the thing that i posted on there for
days called 003 rmd with parameters it's
it's a file that's in
github materials for today and if i
click on it i can see the file it's the
same file we've been looking at
and i could send this to my boss i could
send this to the president of our shoe
tariff he could click on the file he'll
see the same thing that i can
and if he wants to change this to look
at a different
drug he doesn't need to interact with
the art code at all he could use the tab
in rsu connect
and he could choose his drug here about
ass
aspirin and he could run the report
the code that i wrote for this report is
now being executed by our studio connect
on a server somewhere it doesn't matter
that i have r on my computer
that's just you know because i'm me but
you could go here
and if you had access to document you
could run this without downloading r
here we could see some things about
aspirin
the other thing is since all the codes
here to regenerate this report whenever
i want it'd be very easy for me to do
things like
schedule it to be updated whenever i
know that the data itself is getting
updated
it'd be very easy for me to update this
report and automatically email it to my
collaborator collaborators every monday
or tuesday
it'd be in it'd be very easy to see how
people have been interacting with this
report or how this report has changed
over time perhaps by looking at the
version history or
something else here
we'll learn all about that in two weeks
and the rco
can connect our suitconnect and
production webinar
all right so that wraps up this webinar
here is the link rstd.ios repro in
production
it has versions of the file that i was
developing today
at different waypoints so you could see
all of the the different technology i
put in there
and uh and thank you thank you for
for sticking out to this webinar if
there's any questions i'll do my best to
try to answer them now
have any surveys been done on what
percent of data scientists use
computational documents versus those
that don't
i'm not aware of that research steve i
think computational documents are sort
of
in the early adoption phase it does also
depend on how you
how liberally you want to find defined
computational documents but what i have
seen anecdotally
is that adoption is spreading
so the percentage data science using
these things will will be increasing
will page now be covered in this webinar
or any others in the series
i know ryan page down
isn't um it's very interesting but not
really central to the topic we're
covering today so we won't go over page
down
however if you go to
ourmarkdown.orgstudio.com formats that
link in the slides
you'll you'll find a link where you can
learn much more about page down it is
one of the formats
how do we handle reproducibility when
packaged versions change it
package version changes may cause
results to change
can we force a certain version of each
package
yes you can do that depending on
on your use case if if you have a budget
if you work for a company that's
supporting your work with our
professionally then you might look into
the rstudio package manager which is a
tool designed
specifically to do this to help your
group
keep track of which versions of packages
are being used for what
it makes it very simple to reproducibly
track which packages should be used when
and then to
to create libraries of those packages to
use with certain projects
you can learn more about our studio
package manager at rstudio.com
it's part of the new rstudio team bundle
if you were
if you're working as an individual
depending on your work and how you use
it
you might find rsu package manager
useful to you as well again if you're
uh academic lab or whatnot but if you
don't want to use our suit package
manager
you can check out some of the open
source solutions that sort of get at
this problem like
the rn package renv in the
the pre-existing pack rat package
p-a-c-k-r-a-t
uh handling changes
in versions in open source software is
probably the trickiest problem
related to reproducibility when you use
open source software there are many
people working on this problem
uh i recommend r2 package manager
because i know it's a very professional
solution that will work but obviously
when you talk about open source software
we're not always looking for
professional solutions
can you please repeat the difference
between r setup versus r
for the code chunks yes and
let's go to the code and take a look at
that uh
if i go back to the one that is
developing here the first chunk has the
word setup in it
and the other chunks don't you could
give any chunk you want it
a label so i might call this one graph
that'll help me remember that uh you
know this is the chart that contains the
graph
and if you're inside r studio down here
you can navigate the chunks like jump
chunk one two three
if i use a label it's much easier to
figure out which chunk i'm looking for
because the labels show up here
and they're kind of used in other places
too
but our markdown itself will use one of
the labels in a special way
if you name a chunk setup then whenever
you try to run any code in this document
say this was a brand new document i just
opened it up you can see here this
in the setup chunk i'm sourcing some
needed functions i'm creating the data
set that's needed down here for events
you know here's where events has created
but you can imagine
excuse me a second
you can imagine sharing this file with a
colleague and they just want to make the
graph
they're excited to make the graph so
they come down here they open the file
they don't create the data they don't
run this
any of that code up there this try to
create the graph
well if events doesn't exist they would
get an error message
but if you put events or anything else
in the setup chunk then no matter what
chunk it's run
first our markdown will ensure that the
setup chunk is run
before that chunk so the setup chunk is
an ideal place to load your packages
uh to download data if the report relies
on it
to set up intermediate objects that the
chunks below rely on
the setup chunk will always be run at
least
one time before anything else in the
document gets run and that's why i use
the setup chunk label here how does our
markdown handle html widgets when
rendering
into a pdf in html by edgar that's a
great question edgar
html widgets actually return javascript
they return a javascript widget
and if you put that into an html
document which is then
presented by a web browser they'll know
what to do with that h
that javascript widget and it's going to
work and there are multiple
our markdown formats that rely on html
there's i o slide presentations
other types of slideshows blog down book
down
anything that's html based html widgets
will work in
but html widgets are not pdf widgets uh
pdf files are largely static
and they don't recognize html widgets so
if you were to output that file to pdf
html which it would not appear
you would not be able to have an
interactive pdf you could think of pdfs
really
for printing and you know anything you
print out
is not going to be very interactive
unless
origami's involved i guess
how would you generate both reports as
separate documents
but not edit run each time
all right so i'm going to assume we have
a parametrized report and we're talking
about prednisone we're talking about
tylenol
if i go back to our studio this is the
parameters version report it's called o7
temp
i'm going to open the console here
because if i want to generate both those
reports and not
have to use the nip button or whatever i
would
use the r markdown render function
i would pass it this 07
temp.rmd document
this will render it if i just render it
like this it's going to use the default
values for these params
parameters up here
then let me
i was also missing there but let me uh
consult the help page so i don't give
out any
incorrect advice i could set the
parameter values i want to use
in the r markdown render call
right here with the params argument okay
so it just prims itself
so i go in here put my double colon in
there
can i go two window out of the way set
params
equal to a list and here i could say
you know i want drug equal to
tylenol and you know if i cared about
doctor i don't actually use it i would
set that here to
close you know a
and then when i run this document it
will use those parameters there
i could also set out the the output file
name
set that to
output file equals uh you know oh seven
tylenol or something
the rmd okay so how's that answer your
question
no but it set up the solution if you can
generate this document programmatically
like this
you could write a for loop that calls
this a number of times and each time it
calls it
it passes in a different set of
parameters
and it passes in a different file path
to save the results at
and by the time that for loop finishes
running you'll have
you know i different documents each uses
different parameters and each is saved
in its own place
and that's how you can generate 100
reports right away from a parametrized
document
all right next we're at the we're coming
up on
five minutes remaining and it looks like
we have a lot of questions
so first i'll say we'll post the
questions
and garrett if you're open to it you can
answer them in text format and we'll
have a thread for that
on community.rstudio.com and then i
would say for the remaining couple of
minutes do you want to
pick and choose you know a couple more
just to go through
that sounds like a great plan let's see
um
can you double check
all right well okay so some questions
close to my heart was the best way to
start learning r for experienced
programmers
i think the book r for data science
would be the place to start if you just
want to
use r to analyze data but if you want to
understand r
as a language using what you already
know about software languages
as an experienced programmer then i'd
recommend starting with the book
advanced r
by hadley wickham both r for data
science and advanced r
are available for free online or you
could purchase a print copy
when you have interactivity does the
data have to be on the server or
available for a general user to interact
with
that's a good question because it gets
to
to an important nuance between shiny and
non-shiny things
i go back to the slides if we're looking
about the slide here
shiny is a way to have an r session
running in the background that the user
can interact with
and that allows all sorts of things
because the user at any moment can do
anything that r can do as long as you
provide a way for them to do that
and shiny is the only technology that
allows that to happen html widgets do
not
parameters do not parameters will use r
to create the document and then
r goes away and you could take that
parameterized document print it out take
it offline do whatever you want
html widgets will build a self-contained
widget they will
when you build html widget it puts in
every possibility
for interaction in that widget if you
have a map widget it puts in the map of
the whole world
which means you could take that offline
and poke around in the widget and move
around and
it's going to work for you it's only
when you get to shiny
that you need to have an r session
running somewhere in the background
now our session could be in in a couple
places it could be on your own computer
if you have r installed
if you open the document in our student
you click run you don't need to be
connected to the internet
or serious just go use your local r
session to power that shiny app and it
will work for you
the second way you could do it is you
could put that shiny app online either
with
on our studio connect on shiny server
pro or on shinyapps.io
these are all servers that are designed
to run in our session in the background
to power those shiny apps
that means that there's an important use
case that you pay attention to if you're
using
shiny you need to make sure that your
server can run in our session in the
background
and you know most web servers aren't
designed to run our sessions so
use your options generally to use you
know
one of the three i mentioned or also
open source shiny server
so i'll leave that there except this is
bringing us to the top of the hour
thank you very much everyone for your
questions and for your attention